hello everyone welcome back to the
channel for another south by southwest
2022
interview i have the team behind spin me
around here jeff allison aubry molly
alessandro
hello
congratulations and thank you for this
very interesting but very good time
thank you
thank you perry all right so with a
festival premiere a lot of our audience
will not know what your movie is about
just yet so jeff i'll give you these
honors will you give us a brief
description of spin me around yeah so
spin around is about a um manager at a
franchise restaurant in america who wins
an all expense paid trip to italy to the
country to the um restaurants institute
to learn about food wine and culture
um and she thinks it's gonna be this
romantic getaway and it turns out to be
a little bit more dark and messed up
fair description right there so
i have a i have a very random silly
group question to start here but i
started to think about it myself for for
each of you you get to go on a getaway
courtesy of the food brand you eat the
most or the food chain that you visit
the most what is the company that you go
on this trip with and what do you look
forward to most about that trip
uh
i would get pellegrino
trip and i guess i would go to italy
which would be great and that's perfect
i can't think of a brand i was gonna say
i love hummus i love
greek food maybe i could go to greece
and i'd be eating lots of
greek salads although i feel like i've
never been to greece and i've heard that
greek food is maybe actually different
than i think of as like americanized
greek food so maybe that would but give
me some you know olives
like maybe there's not as much hummus in
actual greek food now and now this is
terrible mediterranean food i don't know
i think i would go try different ramens
and go to tokyo kyoto and go to all the
different best ramen places
in japan
like that i like that yeah
sometimes i like to
have locker roll um
licorice um hard candies
um they're from scandinavia so um which
i love love to go to sweden or norway or
any of the nordic countries and
have some really bitter candies
yum
uh well i
i guess my soft spot is peanut m m's
so
is there like a is there a um
like a factory like charlie and the
chocolate factory kind of thing where
they make those because i could go there
hershey pennsylvania yeah hershey
pennsylvania that's where i'd go
yeah
you make me feel better about my answer
you all pick these exotic locations but
i'm like the peanut butter company i
want to visit their farm in arkansas so
i can make peanut butter
oh that's terrible but then i decided
i heard peanuts are bad for your
prostate so
maybe i should
get a new uh weakness
i just read that they're the fourth
healthiest nut that you could eat but
maybe that's just for women
yes i was shocked yeah
walnuts are the most healthy they're
very good for your brain walnuts are the
most healthy and pistachios i was
surprised was the second one and brazil
nuts i knew but you shouldn't eat too
many but they're good for your thyroid
and then peanuts i guess walnuts are
good for breast cancer breasts
preventing breast cancer
oh good i heard green tea is good for
that too two things i love
i've already learned so much on this
call thank you for that
allison and jeff i'm going to throw this
next question to you can you tell
everybody what inspired this idea to
begin with there's there's a lot going
on in this film so what was the idea
that kicked it all off
well it was jeff's original idea and
pretty i think pretty much right after
we finished shooting the little hours
about five or six years ago uh that was
such a great experience and shooting in
italy is so it's so beautiful there it's
so fun we all love the culture and the
food and i i sort of think he came up
with this idea right after we shot that
just as a
as a means of just getting back to italy
and doing another movie there um but the
movie didn't come together at that time
and then in the interim he and i
wrote horse girl together and
co-produced that and made that in los
angeles and it went so well it was such
a good experience molly was in that as
well it's a you know it's all the the
jeff bana players
so after we did horse girl
jeff sort of circled back and was like i
have this idea about these managers
going to italy and
the trip is not what they expect and
then it kind of spins out of control and
at the time he had
like a 10-page outline written
and was like do you want to come on
board and kind of flesh this out with me
and so we did expand it into a 35 page
outline you know the little hours and
horse girl were both improvised movies
based on outlines and that's what we
intended for this but then because of
kovid
we had a lot of time on our hands and we
ended up just writing the whole script
together over zoom
uh which was really fun because we got
to
just yeah really kind of pull all the
characters apart in different directions
and uh hone in on
some things in terms of my character and
her arc over the course of the movie and
things like that and
and as
usual
in
my experiences writing with jeff it's
it's a lot of pulling from personal
experience you know in this case i feel
like
jeff came in with this the the
the broad strokes of the idea for the
whole movie and then we kind of go back
and forth telling crazy stories from our
lives and a lot of them get incorporated
into the film
all right so bringing up the idea of
many of you working together before
molly and aubry i'll throw this next
question to you so you've both worked
with jeff as a director a number of
times now what is it about his sets and
his way of working that keeps you coming
back for more well jeff has an amazing
visual ability like you just feel so
confident when he's shooting something
with his eye and how he sees stuff and
how he shoots stuff even if he just
takes a photograph it's like the best
photograph ever so the way he has
superior visual ability and then on top
of that he's very funny so
that combination is very rare in
hollywood i feel somebody usually has
one or the other not they're not able to
shoot comedy with beauty
so that's one thing i just adore about
jeff um and i will say
that um
i think jeff has like a really amazing
talent to write stuff that is so funny
but also has this kind of underlying
sweetness
to it he loves is he loves his
characters so much and um
and it's like it's just a very specific
tone and really unique and it's really
nice to to work with someone that that
has a completely fully realized vision
in their in their minds and it's kind of
like you can kind of just like let go
and just you know
go along for the ride because he really
knows what he wants so it's like a
really it's a really it's a really fun
uh process as an actor because you feel
like you're in really good hands all the
time i feel like that balance you
described is what keeps me coming back
for more as a viewer so i very much
agree with that all right alexandra so
this is your first time working with a
whole bunch of creators here who have
worked together pretty often so what was
it like stepping into their world and
then
was there anything about the environment
on set that kind of made you go like i
see why they keep coming back for more
and keep doing this uh i kind of felt
yeah i mean it i i kind of felt like an
alien who had been dropped into their
midst and uh
because i had like
weirdly there's this big
there's a big divide in in
movies between like
the comedy people and the dramatic
people or whatever and
and some of these actors like uh evil
hag and and uh allison ree
uh are starting to kind of like you know
you know span
both of those worlds but i
uh but for sure like
everybody in the comedy world knows each
other really well and a lot of them came
up together and
improv stuff and you know chicago and
all that and um
and
uh where you know and the same is true
and on the other side uh
and obviously i've worked with a lot of
people but weirdly just like i had no
connection with
anybody uh
on this movie and um
i just was sent
little hours and
i just thought it was so funny and
so real
um
and so i i i just i love the style of it
um
but yeah no i not only was i like in a
way kind of the odd man out because
everybody had worked together and knew
each other but i for some reason i can't
remember why
started like two weeks later than
everybody else
and this was like one of the first
movies back from covid where everybody
was shooting again and everybody was
staying in this hotel in tuscany and
they'd been here for like two weeks
and it's just been raging together for
like you know the whole time until i got
there and they were all like
uh just you know they've been up till
like this watching the sun come up
almost every night in fact the night
that i arrived there
i was told the next day that at like 6
00 a.m that next morning that they were
temp they'd been talking about coming
and banging on my door to wake me up and
just like you know do some prank on me
or some [ __ ] and and then they'd like
gotten too shy
did you read my cards
um so it was like yeah i was thrown into
their midst but um
they're just the kind of coolest crowd
and uh i was just feeling
so lucky to be
part of them and i spent most of the
time kind of like with this shit-eating
grin on my face and like you know like
little slits for eyes you know well
because everybody was so funny and
i didn't really know what to say also
remember your first day when we took you
to the beach
yeah
yeah that was a great first day first
day we just like
piled in a convertible and there was
like
italian pop music playing and we went
down to some like little club down on
the
near pisa right and
then parts of the morning
did something happen that i'm forgetting
except for just like
a perfect day no we took you in to be
like we baptized you
yeah they had like a weird
like seance
there was like a group like a chain
everybody formed a chain around me or
something right
oh yeah
it was a great i should have worked
i should have worn a speedo that would
have freaked you guys out and now
alessandra when he shows up speaks
fluent italian to all the waiters
remember that like when we had dinner
you would be like
that was they didn't understand a word i
was saying you guys just thought that i
was
you
know so alessandro i would not mind
seeing you doing more comedies because i
feel like it's been a little while since
i've seen you in a movie like this so
working with such big powerhouses in
that particular genre is there anything
you saw someone else do on this set that
you know you're kind of putting in your
back pocket and waiting to do on another
comedy that you you're a part of i don't
know i mean the funny thing was that
like these guys were all sort of
heavy improvers but
none of this movie was improved
right i mean it was like
very scripted in a great way and i think
thank god for me because like if it had
been the other way around then
i would have just like stood there like
a deer in the headlights but
um
because it was kind of like
i think was that was is that because
that's not normally how you shoot right
jeff like normally you guys
play sort of fast and loose with it but
this time was it there was like time
constraints or you just like had like
scripted it more before you started
because you were selling the the project
or i can't remember what well
we were supposed to shoot it that summer
of 2020 and then covet captain so we um
had to put a put a pin in it and then in
the interim
uh alice and i just decided to write it
out but yeah we had originally written
an outline which is how i've done my
last three movies
where it's sort of this the stories are
beated out and the dialogue is sort of
like suggested and you know for the most
part kind of
lightly sketched so that other people so
the actors can
kind of speak in their own voices um
but we just decided for sake of time and
you know the
i guess for the to have the best
opportunity to make this and have as
much time as possible we thought it
would be a good idea to raise the script
but it was pretty mean like my first day
i think i had to come into that scene
where i had to like start crying during
the the what should we call it game what
was the the yeah
yeah
the mafia yeah
and i've never met anybody
and uh yeah that was day one um
anyway no i mean it just it was amazing
watching all of them everybody is
um everybody
every performer in it had something
about
uh
himself or herself that was just so kind
of
unique and strange and funny just even
if they did just say you know
anything and so
uh it was brilliantly cast and i know it
was people that he worked with before
but everybody seemed to slot into their
different roles so
perfectly
i would say that the timing actually
worked out amazingly well because
alessandro's character sort of looms
large overall the characters you know
before they before and after they meet
him in the movie so
i felt like to the rest of us it was
really nice that there was this delay
before alessandra got there and we shot
all these scenes kind of talking about
nick nick and then when he got there
everyone had the feeling like our
characters to be so excited he's here
he's here
uh
yeah he played out in real time
anyway yeah i mean i hope he'll have me
back is the bottom line i only go to
south by southwest with comedies because
the last time i was there was
the art of self-defense which was
really the only other like i don't know
comedy that i've done but
a riley stearns comedy is a very
specific form of comedy i feel like i
don't put it into the broader category
because he's such a like a unique uh
storyteller there i don't even know how
to classify his movies um i'm a little
surprised to hear that you stuck to the
script so much and in particular with
your character molly because you have so
many moments in this movie that go on
for too long but in the best possible
way
and
like the time the timing on it is
especially well done where i get the
impression that you kind of have to feel
something like that out on the spot so
was that the case or was there i guess
more precision to planning how a beat
like that will play um well let's see um
well like specifically the one scene
where i go ask allison to borrow clothes
um yeah jeff really let that
play out
but you have to you have to be with you
know
i two things that were great components
in that scene is alison is such an
amazing actress like she's so good and
she plays it so straight in that scene
and then jeff knows how to shoot that
comedy and not not everybody does some
people will not know how to do that you
know they'll cut at the wrong point well
with jeff he gets that it's funny and
that it's and that playing it long makes
it funnier and more awkward so
that we could improvise a little bit
right jeff yeah
yeah i mean oh yeah you definitely
improvise the stuff about borrowing the
hangers
but it was also like but it was very
once
you were improvising while we were
rehearsing it and like the hangers the
jean jacket a lot of it was scripted as
a long scene and then you found a bunch
of extra moments and then we just locked
them in and it was like it really was
like choreographed because remember you
had to like take the clothes in the same
order every
time it became one of those heavily
choreographing it's a testament to how
incredible molly is but i would say that
all of molly's scenes in this are
slightly peppered with some of her
improv in the hallway when she's yelling
at me
you know when we were shooting that and
molly was like but i could let me have a
little fun with it we're like go molly
go in the in the room when she comes
back in smoking the cigarette i mean
it's my favorite that might be one of my
favorite teams i've ever shot but
borrowing the clothes and then i also
love when you two are really cool and
i'm like i wanna hang out you guys like
really dorky you know what i mean
like she's so clueless that she's not
wanted and it was just a very fun
character to play yeah i think like you
were kind of asking about working with
the same people and i you know i one of
the benefits of working with people is
obviously you get to know them and trust
them and
you get such a deeper richer performance
when you know people and when you can
kind of write for them and you know how
to work with them and you've done it
before and everyone sort of has a
rapport with each other and a shorthand
and so the benefits of working with
people over and over again is that you
do get to kind of go to places you
wouldn't get to go with people that
you've just met but then also having new
people come in like alessandro and um
tim and zach woods
the people like i absolutely respect and
love and think they're amazing having
the people that have worked there before
kind of set the tone a little bit and
it's sort of an easier transition for
for the newer people to kind of just
slot in and sort of feel comfortable
because it doesn't feel like complete
chaos it feels like there are
sort of like well worked out areas and
then these people can kind of come in
and sort of feel at home and comfortable
without sort of everyone is like flying
blind
so i wanted to end with a a festival
question i guess i i feel i feel
inclined to toss it to you aubrey
because we just spoke for emily the
criminal which is fantastic and
congratulations on that distribution
deal i was very happy for you but
what you like you have the opportunity
to work on all these big films out there
but you and allison and jeff like you're
so consistent on the festival circuit so
what keeps you coming back to
that form of filmmaking and also that
way to get it out into the world because
covering festivals is one of my favorite
things in the world i love discovering
hidden gems so to see people like you
with such big platforms keep returning
to it
it fills my heart
um i mean independent
films are my absolute favorite
thing ever um i like all kinds of movies
i love big movies and
i love all kinds of movies but um
there's just something about independent
films for me that is probably the most
fulfilling
and rewarding experience
because
they just feel like miracles every time
you make them um and
i think you know it's like
acting as such a specific kind of
job and the way that your experiences
you know with each job affect your life
is so um
crazy and i just always find that
independent films are just
they're just magical journeys every time
and so um and festivals are like you
know they're the best
they're the best places for me because
it's just packed with people that are
there for the same reasons for the love
of movies and i just love movies so much
um
so i think it's just kind of
i i hope i never
stop getting to go to festivals because
um it's it's why i want to be in movies
really because i want to be around
surrounded by people that
you know love the process and and try to
make art and try to make things for you
know about the human condition and not
you know not try to like make
just content or products or whatever the
[ __ ] people do but like just yeah
so um
happy to always be at a festival and
um yeah since i
it's my favorite kind of i wish i was
there i'm so sad that i can't be there
in person right now
me too i was gonna say one more thing
one more thing that that um aubrey
started and jeff um was aubry work with
michael caine so she did this amazing
thing where we would shoot but then have
these big dinners after and i i was
actually just talking about you last
night aubry to vanessa bear who i'm
working with and she was like oh but it
really is so
because aubrey picked that up from
michael kane right aubry
yes michael kane
put it into my head that like when
you're shooting a movie it's like
you know maybe that's how it was in the
old days but he was like you know
the way i do it is we shoot all day long
and then every night we go to dinner i
put on my dinner jacket and we go to
dinner and we have wine and um and we
tried to adopt that kind of approach in
italy where you know even though we were
exhausted and all losing our minds we
just really just kind of like
you know
dove fully in and just try to have that
experience and i think it it really yeah
it's like
it's the best
version of filmmaking i think we you
went for it it was
a really special time i love that and
not enough people out there saw best
sellers that movie was a big charmer i
like that one quite a bit
huge congratulations to all of you on
spin me around keep an eye out for it
everyone thank you congratulations and
enjoy the premiere
you